the stock market's panicking but you
don't have to
yeah I mean it it's really uh if you
have money now it'll be a great time to
make money you can buy stocks at you
know it you know when they hit a floor
or when you think they're at a floor you
can buy Bitcoin this is when people get
rich right rich people get even richer
when they have the opportunity to go in
and swoop in and buy things
um that other so I mean I don't know if
you are in a financial position to
monitor this stuff and go in and buy
some stuff it could be nice
and you could look back on it years from
now why don't you but why don't we buy
baby formula and sell it like like buy
it up in bulk could we do that is there
any law preventing us probably but from
buying baby formula in bulk and then
going to poor areas and selling it
yeah because grocery stores can buy them
in bulk right so so could we I mean it's
a great idea to just buy instead of
merch on our website let's just sell
baby formula at an increased cost it's
called Arbitrage it happens all the time
buy baby formula and sell it to be and
let's be it's not the time this is great
now they're overturning Roe v Wade
nobody has formula
those babies do not need to be here
truly and the reality is those babies
are going to show up hungry for formula
which we don't have so it's time for the
Supreme Court to [ __ ] relax and
[ __ ] extend abortion to seven or
eight months even
really on the operating day at this
point the economy demands on the
operating table depending on the price
of formula that day you should be able
to
get rid of it
if formula is high the week before
you're about to give birth
they should have a special before they
overturn Roe v Wade what if they did
this they're going to overturn it but
they said for the next six months
because of the shortages on formula and
how expensive everything is we are
planning to overturn Roe v Wade but for
the next six months abortion is legal up
into and including day of birth
hmm just to you know
just get in while the getting's good
and then we're Banning it um
but up to including the day of birth
where they will you literally give birth
to a baby
and they give it lethal injection
[Laughter]
on the Opera what on the operating table
because right now we financially can't
do it it's like have you ever wanted a
puppy and your parents had to go we
can't do it right now
people are desperate we we can't even
control the babies we have here in our
country we certainly can't be bringing
we should do a Chinese style ban on
birth
uh not I'm not even for 100 percent
get a Bitcoin if you want to have a kid
and see if you can watch that for a year
with the highs and lows of that it's
[ __ ] pretty much like a lot of people
say oh having kids greatest thing in
your life have you owned a Bitcoin the
highs and the lows all your kids your
kids just want a a [ __ ] hockey game
everyone's happy Bitcoins I oh the kid
broke his arm in the next hockey game
I'm worried bitcoin's low
a Bitcoin is a perfect uh replacement
for a child all the highs and lows that
you used to get from a traditional
nuclear family structure you can now get
from cryptocurrency yes or yes yes
you don't need a bunch of children
running around your house unless you're
the ant wouldn't you want to do blood
rituals with them you don't need them
running around your house
you can get all of that fulfillment and
drama from Bitcoin
if you own crypto and you watch it go up
and down
what do people do when they have a kid
they have all this mommy [ __ ] right
mommy bloggers they watch YouTubes of
mommy we've got that the crypto
Community has all of that you can watch
a will Clementi that uh [ __ ] uh 19
year old uh autistic twink and he just
sits there and he rattles off things all
day listen all you can clearly
replace your need to have children with
the Bitcoin
the world just buy a Bitcoin a Bitcoin
costs thirty thousand dollars okay
that's essentially the startup cost of
having a baby when you think of the
cribs and the stuff and it only gets
more expensive from there my point is
that it's incredibly irresponsible right
now to have children we need to put like
a year or two moratorium on all birth in
America
where if you if you're laughing but I'm
not wrong the reason China's overtaking
us is because they don't get emotional
about this [ __ ]
moratorium on all birth
for one to two years of every race don't
even come at me with that it's not about
that every race
closed the doctors and hospitals down in
the OB gyns close it down treat mothers
like criminals put them in jail and
forcibly abort their children for a
period of one to two years until the
economy can rebound and give them crypto
while you're give them crypto so they
can [ __ ] have something to watch and
care about every day and look after give
them cryptocurrency take their babies
from them and kill them we don't have
the money it's incredibly selfish to
keep bringing life into this world when
we have artificial intelligence AI we
have enough simulated life we don't need
any more biological life we've got
enough Elon things are getting better
Elon Musk is but he's buying Twitter
he's going to let me threaten to kill my
aunt on Twitter again
things are going to be okay
elon's gonna let me uh put my aunt's
address on Twitter and tell people to go
kill her
I think isn't that what this is about
isn't Elon buying Twitter specifically
so that I can encourage my fans to go
kill my aunt
if that's not what it's about I'm not
even excited about it anymore that's my
question
my question is simply
I'm sick of this baby [ __ ] all the time
I'm sick of arguing about it
I'm saying I'm let's let's not only
should we not ban Roe v Wade
we should ban birth
go the other way and just until
inflation comes down
until the cause how bad is the the cost
right now of the food